[Music]  come on figure out what to do with you  this week on The Walking Dead viewers  got to explore negan sanctuary through  the eyes of Rick's vengeful son Carl I  only one Deegan he killed my friends did  you pick that gun cuz it looks cool he  totally did right after inviting Carl  inside we discovered Meegan is a  polygamist why settle for just one why I  follow the same rules we also learned  Carl is still a little sensitive about  his missing I riced pet is disgusting I  can see your socket speaking of scars we  found out how Dwight got his no shocker  here yet another brutal negan torture  tactic in iron burn  let Mark's face be a daily reminder to  him and to everyone else that the rules  matter and now it seems Darrell might  have a way out of his cell after a note  reading go now was slipped under his  door along with a single match and a key  you